hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
prep for success from human microbiome
exploration to advanced
sars cov2 testing and wastewater i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i will be
your moderator for today's event
today is educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits i now present
today's speaker
dr sasha vlassop senior manager research
and development
life sciences solutions group thermo
fisher scientific
madhu josti staff scientist
sample preparation at thermo fisher
scientific
and emily zehringer staff scientist
sample preparation at thermo fisher
scientific
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
tasha madhu and emily you may now begin
your presentations
thank you hello everyone today we'll be
talking about the good
and the bad bugs from human microbiome
exploration to advanced
sarco v2 research in wastewater and the
human samples
now daily life we primarily focus on
macro objects we observe human
beings animals plants other things but
there is an invisible universe of micra
and nano objects
what the slide shows not surprisingly in
terms of global biomass
plants are number one and they are
contributing the estimated 450 gigatons
of
carbon animals contribute only two
gigatons and the rest are microbes
bacteria are at 70 giga tons of carbon
and proteus virus
viruses and other contributing more
so despite the small size all these
microbes are present at a combined huge
mass
substantially more than all humans and
animals on planet earth
most of the microbes populate the
environment they are found in a thick
layer of soil and water
but many of them populate human body
some of the microbes are our friends
some of them are our enemies and today
we'll be talking about both
healthy human microbe microbiome some
abnormalities and the deadly viruses
such as sars
which are coming from the surrounding
environment and affect us
our health and our microbiome
the human body primarily the gut is
populated by 100 trillion bacteria and
other members of the
microbiota community which play a
fundamental role in our well-being
bacteria best type members of human
microbiome
much more work needs to be done with
characterization of fungi
and the bacteriophages and it's
intriguing to see that
there are different submicrobiomes
within the human body such as skin
eye nose ear mouth etc different
communities that
populate parts of our body and they
unique and different
of the large number of functions and
beneficial effects uh
various microbes exert within the human
body only fraction
is well understood at the moment because
as you can imagine the studies are
extremely challenging
but it is truly impressive even in this
little segment that we understand is
really amazing
for instance it is known that human
microbes prevent colonization by
pathogens by competing for attachment
sites and for essential nutrients
they antagonize competitors and foreign
bacteria through the production
substances ranging from
relatively non-specific fatty acids and
peroxides to highly specific
bacteriocenes
microbes perform carbohydrate
fermentation absorption
enabling the host to utilize some
normally indigestible carbohydrates
they synthesize and excrete vitamins b
and k
in excess of their own needs which can
be absorbed
as nutrients by their host microbes also
provide a continuous and dynamic effect
on the host's gut
and systemic immune systems
and finally they also stimulate the
development of certain tissues
it's a very impressive list and this is
just the beginning of the journey
deviations from healthy microbial
composition have been linked with many
human diseases
including inflammatory bowel disease
obesity
cancer asthma diabetes and allergies
there are many diagnostic tests and
therapeutic solutions based on human
microbiome
live bacteria and the agents promoting
or inhibiting growth of certain microbes
some of these agents are in development
some of them are already commercially
available
the most famous story is fecal
microbiota transplant or
fmt which was approved by fda about a
year ago
as a treatment for a current c difficile
infection
this procedure is now used in every
country in the world and every state
with the united states of america
to summarize we need to treat microbiome
as a sophisticated system
much like the circulatory or immune
systems
that exist in harmony with hemostasis
play multiple
roles within the human body and the
complexity is truly fascinating
there are different questions that can
be asked by scientists and medical
specialists in their studies of bacteria
viruses and other microbes who is there
what can they do what are they actually
doing
and this will dictate the tools and
workloads for analysis
keep in mind that many bacteria
especially from our gi
tract cannot be cultured and that's why
only when molecular techniques
especially sequencing became available
this area of research exploded and it
happened very recently only about 10
years
ago so over the last decade a tremendous
amount of
data was generated many exciting studies
were
published in the top profile journals
and
lately if you attend different
conferences you can absorb plenty of
information about this really exciting
area
of research so then our presentation
will focus on analysis of bacterial
and viral rna and dna we won't be
discussing proteomics or metabolobics
these are separate areas of studies and
i will be presenting on that later
another topic that we'll be covering
today is a very exciting it's a sarco v2
research
using human and environmental samples
the bulk of research
and testing is done on esophageal swabs
and saliva from different donors
but sars is also reliably detected in
human stool at the early stage of
infection and for several subsequent
weeks
based on this finding wastewater sewage
surveillance became an extremely useful
tool
for monitoring the regional spread of
sarco v2
and the other viral and bacterial
pathogens
hundreds of organizations worldwide are
successful using wastewater testing for
surveillance at the city level
as well as for zooming in as required
for early catch cases for instance
dorms at the university maybe many of
you saw this
announcements in the news over the last
couple of months
today two of our scientists will be
giving presentations madhu will first
talk about the human microbiome research
tools and analysis by next gen
sequencing and the qpcr
and latest developments briefly
highlighting effects of diet and
probiotics on the microbiome composition
of gi tract
in the second part of presentation she
will talk about the wastewater testing
for
sarcov2 surveillance and then emily will
be giving a presentation about
methods and workflows for analysis of
viral bacterial and other pathogens by
qpcr
highlighting the latest solutions for
sarco v2 testing
at the discovery phase when you don't
know who is out there negan sequencing
is obviously the best approach
but once you know which organisms you
want to detect and
explore in detail quantitative pcr using
technology
is the fastest cost effective most
sensitive and specific approach
with that i will pass the microphone to
madu
thank you sasha this is madhu jayaki
i'm a staff scientist at thermo facial
scientific
my presentation is about the human
microbiome
and gut health
what is microbiome and why do we need to
know about this microbiome
microbiome is a group of microbes in a
particular
environment so human body consists of
20 thousand human genes and we
also have two to twenty million
microbial genes
that means for every one human gene
we have hundred microbial genes
and only 10 of our cells are human
we have 10 trillion human cells and 100
trillion
microbial cells 10 times higher
and the remaining 90 of the cells are
from
vital bacterial and fungal taxa
over 100 trillion microbes exist in
different parts of the human body
out these the prominent microbiomes in
the human body
are in the mouth which is saliva
has 20 billion microbes and the skin
has 500 species of microbes
that means for every square centimeter
on our skin
we have a billion micro and the next one
is the digestive tract which is gut
which has thousand known species of
bacteria
which contributes to two to five pounds
of our weight and out of all these
prominent microbiomes
the most studied microbiome is the
digestive tract
which is gut why the gut microbiome
is more important because it is the
largest
densest and most diverse microbial
community
in the human body there are several
factors
that affect the gut microbiota that
include
how the baby is born like c-section
or normal delivery or how the baby is
fed
formula fed or breastfed and
environment genetics lifestyle
diet nutrition probiotics antibiotics
prebiotics age everything affects the
cut microbiome
and every person has their own unique
microbiome it's like fingerprint every
person's microbiome
is unique so how do we study viscous
microbiome
using the fecal dna and arnold
thermo fissure offers a wide variety of
tools
for microbiome workflows the first
column here
shows the tools that thermo fisher
offers
for sample collection and analysis of
intact microbes
and the middle top portion shows the
tips
for microbiome analysis fuelling
microbiome kit
and magmax microbiome kit which is the
newly launched kit
and most of my data that i'm showing
today is based on this magmax microbiome
kit
and thermo pressure also offers the
stabilizing solutions for nucleic acids
like rna mater and offers the instrument
for automation the kingfisher flex and
duo
and for the downstream analysis of
microbial dna
and rna thermo fisher offers the iron
torrent platform
and also adm microbiome array
let's look at the data and the workflow
for this magmax microbiome
alpha kit magmax microbiome workflow
for rapid total nucleic acid
purification
we have both options manual and
automatic
automated options for this microbiome
kit
so basically from the stool sample it
takes
50 minutes less than an hour to
extract the total nucleic acid from the
toughest
sample like stool so for the hands-on
part in this workflow is the sample
pre-processing
for this we have two options using the b
tube
and a bead plate so we do the bead
beading
to light all the tough organisms tough
microbes in the stool sample
so for the high throughput options we
can do the 96 well
plate we can use the 96 well plate
for 96 sample using the high throughput
blue beater
after pre-processing the sample the
binding
washes and illusion of the total nucleic
acid
happens on the kingfisher and
if you look at the picture next to it
the red square
shows how good the kit is so
basically it's a high yielding kit
giving eels up to
70 micrograms and we can process 96
samples within an hour it's the high
throughput option
and we have several protocols designed
for several sample types using this
script
let's look at the data how the kits work
so the first picture here shows the one
percent
agarose gel with the total nucleic acid
isolated from
six donor fecal samples shown in
duplicate
the first plane indicates the kd plus
ladder
shown for five comparisons and the top
band is the dna band
isolated and the bottom two bands
are the rna bands the ribosomal bands
for rna
16s and 23s so this gel picture
showing that the peps isolated the total
nucleic acid effects
isolated using the skips are high
quality prep
and to assess the rna quality the sample
from these prep rnas is
loaded onto the agilent bio analyzer
using the rna nano chip
and the agilent bio analyzer trace is
shown here for the rna
so basically the ring value the rna
integrity number
is ranging from 8 to 9.5 for different
donor prep
and you can see the quality of rna on
the trace here
showing two ribosomal bands 16s 23s
along with some small rna these results
indicate that microbiome kit enable high
quality
spread then we did the downstream
analysis
the nucleic acid analysis downstream
using the applied biosystem
tacman assays
this is the pacman assay data for the
dna isolated using the microbiome kit
using the tacman probes for gram
negative bacteria
bacteroides and gram positive bacteria
for mature so these fermicutes and
bacteroids
are the phyla which includes several
species in there
basically these probes detect multiple
species
in those classes it's not like a single
target
so the graph shown here line graph shows
the cp values on the y-axis
and the total nucleic acid extracted
analyzed from
six critical samples is shown on the
x-axis
so we were able to detect good cp values
for both the target gram positive and
gram-negative
indicating that this kit enables
efficient isolation of total nucleic
acid
from gram positive and gram-negative
targets
and this is the data from the analysis
of rna
using the same pac-man probe for
gram-positive negative targets
bacteroides and and the ct
is shown on the y-axis so we were able
to detect good cp values for all the six
critical
samples again indicating that
microbiome kit enables efficient
isolation of total nucleic acid
from both gram-positive and
gram-negative targets
so the next thing is how does this kit
work for other sample types
if you look at the vertebrae kingdom we
have several
classification there mammals
birds reptiles and fish
and amphibians so i was able to collect
the fecal samples from
all the vertebrates except the
amphibians so those were all tested
along with some fungal targets and the
bottom picture shows the stool samples
collected from
all these different organisms it's
looking like a
rainbow this
is the taqman assay data shown for
all these samples collected and
extracted using the magmax microbiome
kit
the top graph is the 16s pacman assay
data
so the ct values for the 16s
which is the microbe levels are detected
using this kit using the several
vertebrates here
like human cat dogs hamster ferrets
those are the mammals and fish and the
reptiles
included bearded dragon and emerald
swift
and coca teal is a petty looking bird so
from
all these wide range of species we were
able to detect the
microbiome basically microbe levels with
the good ct values
and the bottom graph shows the fungal
target detection
so healthy donor stool samples were
spiked in
with the sea out detents and aspergillus
nizer
which is the first two names shown there
and the last three lanes these were
collected from a grocery store that's
red star eats and fish man's yeast
and a probiotic ginger aid so from all
these samples
pacman assay is done using the pacman
probe for the total fungal target
so the ct values indicate that from all
these samples
we can efficiently isolate the fungal
target using this magmax microbiome kit
so these results show that this kit
works for wide range of sample types
so the next thing we wanted to see is
what is the total microbiome profile
so this is shown with the microbiome
case studies here
so to get the whole microbiome profile
we need to do the sequencing downstream
16f sequencing which is done on the
iron torrent platform offered by
thermofisher
and just to give you some information
before
showing the microbiome profiles from
each donor
so the most common bacterial phyla in
the gut
of healthy donors is mostly occupied by
permacutes
and bacteroides and to certain extent
actinobacteria
and cardio bacteria so let's look at the
microbiome profiles
from the total nucleic acid trap
isolated with this kit
this is the case study one i wanted to
see
whether there is any effect of
probiotics
on the microbiome profile so this case
study is done on a single donor
tested for a single donor that donor
took 12 weeks probiotics
and stool sample was collected before
taking the probiotics before starting
the probiotics
and every week of intake with the intake
of probiotics
and the total nucleic acid traps were
done using this kit
and analyzed the bacterial profiles with
the 16f sequencing
on the ion torrent so this is the data
shown here
the heat map is generated by our studio
the phyla level heat map is shown here
and the scale is given next to it
the scale basically shows if the
scale is like orange to red in color
it's
high level of those targets and yellow
shows the medium level
and the blue shows no are low levels
of the target so if you look at the
before probiotics
the permicute is at high level and with
the intake of probiotics by week 12
the firmicute levels have gone down
bacteroides also started like before
probiotic sample
has medium level whereas with the intake
of probiotics
the levels have gone high and coming to
the proteobacteria
there is no significant difference with
the intake of probiotics
but the actino bacteria they started
at the level before probiotics they were
like medium to low level
and with the intake of probiotics by
every week they have gone down so this
data
is indicating that taking the probiotics
changed the microbiome profile
in terms of formical and bacteroides for
this particular
donor
and the second case study that i did is
effect of
diet on the microbiome so for this
also one donor was tested that donor
followed 16 weeks of diet suggested by a
nutritionist
and this is a strictly vegetarian diet
and the stool sample was collected
before starting the diet
and after 16 weeks of diet so the data
shown
here is the heat map generated by art
studio
so the bottom lane here shows the
profile microbiome profile
from the sample collected before
starting the diet
and the top lane here shows the sample
collected after 16 weeks of diet
and the species detectors were shown
there
and the scale is given on the top so the
red squares
shown here basically show significant
differences in the levels of those
bacterial species before diet versus
after diet for example i can give you
one example here
so the first one allysite that species
is normally
in high levels in a non-vegetarian
uh eating people so because this
diet is strictly vegetarian you can see
that
after diet that species levels have gone
down
same thing goes with the other targets
as well
so this results indicate that intake of
specific dietary components
was created with the microbiome profile
for this donor so the next topic
is the wastewater surveillance for this
wastewater surveillance
why do we need this wastewater
surveillance it is basically needed
for mass monitoring of cov2
so for a mass monitoring this is this
star cov2
as the biomarker so basically from the
human body
human excretion primarily the fecal
stool
enters into the sewerage and transport
via sewer
and we can take the samples from the
sewage
and test for park civo v2 levels
to report the community-wide trend or
intercon we can do the inter community
comparisons
of the south cov2 level in that
particular community
so to do this mass monitoring or
wastewater surveillance
first we need to test whether we can
be able to detect star cov2 in the fecal
samples or not
and we can be able to detect the thought
cov2
in the wastewater sample or not
so the first sample tested for this
purpose
is fecal samples so again fecal samples
in two different ways raw fecal sample
and the rectal swap
both sample types were tested for
cov2 using the spikin of inactivated
virus
so the workflow for the fecal samples is
shown here
we take the fecal raw sample or the
rectal swab sample
and add the buffer add it to the bead
beading plate
do the bead beading and collect the
supernatant after the bead beading
and take the supernatant for the total
nucleic acid extraction
using the kingfisher instrument so for
this
workflow i did the four spiking amounts
for the sarge 3ob
tube for all the raw samples and the
rectal swab samples
and for the raw fecal samples i i have
tested 10 donors here
and for the rectal swab sample 12 donors
were tested here
so this is the data for the fecal sample
testing with the sar civo v2 spike in
so this is the pacman assay data using
the pacman probes for
sart civo v2 specific genes engine
r180 gene and s gene
and also did the inhibitors test
using the xeno xeno is an internal
positive control
offered by thermo fisher to assets for
inhibitors presence in the total nucleic
acid during the extraction
since stool samples have high amount of
inhibition inhibitors
this zener test is shown to show that
whether the samples have inhibitors or
not
so the tagman essay data the first graph
is for the end gene
shows that the cp values are shown on
the y-axis
and all the 10 fecal donor samples
extracted is shown on the x-axis
the fourth spike in volume here the
thousand copies 500 copies 50 copies and
10 copies of star civil v2
is typed in into the healthy donor tool
sample
here and extracted the total nucleic
acid
so the engine data shows that for
all these 10 donors all the four spykins
were detected with good cp values for
all the
engine or gene s gene we were able to
detect all these fourth pythons
and the zero graph shows that
we detect the same ct for all the 10
donors
comparing to zeno control showing that
if there are any inhibitors in the total
nucleic acid extracted
we expect the secret shift but there is
no cp
shape indicating that there is no
inhibition
from the extracted total nucleic acid so
this result is showing that we can
detect
as low as 10 copies from these faecal
samples
with these pythons and this data is from
the rectal swab samples
for soft cov2 cyclin here again
four different start stigo b2 swipings
were done
2 000 copies 1000 copies 200 copies and
20 copies
and pacman s8 probes were used for
engine
rpm and st and xeno assay is also done
to check for inhibition and as you can
see
here also like before for the rectal
swab samples also
all the four cyclins were detected in
all the 12
freckle swab samples extracted here
same is the case with the s gene and
arsene
and the xenograph also shows no ct
shift from all these 12 donors extracted
compared to zero control indicating that
no inhibition from the extracted total
nucleic acid
from the wastewater from the fecal
samples
like cell swab samples
so the next sample type is the waste
water samples
so these waste water samples we got
these from four different counties
and uh this is the picture showing how
the wastewater samples look
like and we have used
two methods of pre-processing direct
method
and a spin filtration method before
explaining
how we proceeded with that
pre-processing
we collected some analytical parameters
for these wastewater samples comparing
to the nucleus free water
so ph conductivity oxidation reduction
potential
and the ion selective electrode which is
basically the ion concentration
in all these wastewater samples
comparing to nucleus
nucleus free water is shown here
so ph is same for all of them including
the clean water
and conductivity is high for the
wastewater samples
compared to the clean water and the
oxidation reduction potential
that is within the normal range for all
the samples including the clean water
but except makes water sample three
has in the negative range indicating
that that sample
has more reducing substances in the
waste water sample
and the isd ion selective electrode
ion concentration is high in the
all-based water samples
compared to the clean water so basically
these analytical parameters are needed
to design
how to treat the wastewater
so the next thing is how did we process
these
pre-process-based wastewater samples the
first method
we followed is the direct method so we
take the
wastewater samples directly into the
multiple wells in a
beating plate do the bead beating pull
the supernatants from the multiple well
and add 2 ml of the supernatant farewell
in a 24 d12 plate and do the total
nucleic acid extraction
on the kingfisher and the downstream
analysis with the tacman assay
and the second method of pre-processing
the wastewater sample
is the spin filtration method which
is so we spin down we take an aliquot of
the waste water sample
pin down at 10 000 g for 30 minutes
to clear all the large debris and we
take that supernatant
and filter through the nalgene 0.45
micron filter
and take that filter chop that filter
out and chop those
pieces add those pieces into the deep
heating plate
and once the bead beating is done in
presence of lysis buffer
those supernatants were taken and soda
nucleic acid is extracted
and downstream analysis is done on the
qpcr instruments using the pacman assays
let's look at the data for these
wastewater samples
so this is basically without any spiking
of charge cov2
we wanted to see whether the samples
that we received
from these counties whether they have
any
detectable levels of star cov2 or not
so for this we process them same way
shown before infiltration and direct
method both
so the graphs here show the green dot
shows the spin filtration method
and the black dot shows the direct
method of processing
and a negative control included here is
the pbs phosphate buffer training
so the pacman assay data here shows that
pbs no ct detector for pdf here
for the if you look at the ng in drag
and for all the wastewater samples
they have detectable levels of star cov2
and this is the same case with the other
genes as well
r and st so this data is
indicating that why the load is detected
even without any
python next we process the waste water
sample
with the spiking of inactivated charge
pvo v2
so this is the data with the direct
method of pre-processing
so tachman assay data for engine rpms
gene
and the xeno data for inhibition
assessment
so if you look at the engine graph all
the four waste water samples
typed in with the eight thousand copies
and four thousand copies
of star civil v2 were giving the ct
values
around 23 to 24 and same is the case
with the
r and s genes and the zeno data
also shows that there is no ct shift
comparing to
xeno control indicating that the total
nucleic acid
extracted from these water waste water
samples
are free of inhibition so this data is
indicating that
vital load is detected with the spike in
of the
inactivated starch cov2 in this direct
method
and the second method of pre-processing
spin filtration methods
this is the data process by this method
and same thing as shown before
so here the spike in amounts used were
five thousand and two thousand five
hundred copies
so they were the ct values were detected
for both the copies
like them for engine sg or steam
and the xeno assay also shows no
inhibition
no ct shift comparing to zero control
so to conclude magmax microbiome ultra
kit
is for faster purification of inhibitor
inhibitor-free
microbial dna and rna from challenging
samples
and we have the automation ready
protocol designed for
kingfisher flex and duo systems
and this is the past procedure allows
for
96 samples processed within an hour
this is the high throughput option and
this kit
is compatible with wide range of sample
types
such as waste tools and swabs
contained in the transport medium along
with these
i have shown you all other vertebrates
and some creamy samples also
and this kit enables reproducible
recovery of
high quality nucleic acids compatible
with broad range of applications
including microarray qpcr and next
generation sequencing
and i would like to thank my team my
mentor especially sasha with the poop
looking like statue there and my
wonderful teammates
and my suggestion is eat healthy
stay healthy and balance your microbiome
thank you so much for your time
and emily we can take you over
thanks to you um thanks to all of our
attendees for dialing in today um uh my
name is emily behringer
and today for this last part of our
webinar
we'll be um talking about pathogens and
microbiota
a detection monitoring with molecular
methods kind of a bit
broader range
organisms used for molecular methods
so first quickly on the agenda i did
want to go a brief introduction
behind molecular methods and kind of
their
benefit and how kind of we look at them
in a few more details around the
workflow around molecular methods
including the benefits of using
high-throughput
protocols and instrumentation as part of
the workflow
and then case studies are examples of
real world samples with these high
throughput
methods so first the introduction
um so when we think of microbial and
pathogen studies we kind of
look at them as falling into one of
three main areas
the first area being viral detection of
specific viral detection and this can
include
rna viruses dna viruses single stranded
double stranded positive negative
these type of workflows also include
can also include easy twice bacteria
the second area we focus on
for studies would be we kind of call it
the all pathogen detection
this will include the viruses and
gram-negative easily bacteria but will
also include the harder to life
organisms such as the gram-positive
bacteria as well as yeast and fungi
the third mine area is for microbiome
research
which maybe provided a very detailed and
comprehensive
description of and so
in the following slides i will focus
more on the viral detection and the
all pathogen detection however for all
three areas
it does encompass multiple sample types
ranging from biofluids to more solid
types such as fecal samples
as well as speedum
and so for each of these areas for the
viral and into the all pathogen
detection of microbes and pathogens is
nothing new it's been around
for quite a while the more traditional
methods
kind of the gold standard they work very
well but they are limited in certain
ways
they are low throughput and often have a
narrow focus
you know looking for one analyte
or one target um and often you
require multiple workflows to get uh the
same answer
to get answer in different ways from the
same
sample and so you can see it kind of
laid out you have your sample type your
micro pathogen of interest your
extraction method analysis method
and each step often has multiple options
or
multiple protocols that must be
completed
so in this day and age where you know
the number of samples
is increasing and the amount of time
um desired to get answers from these
samples is reduced
these traditional methods
you know aren't as useful
and so kind of to lay it out in a more
visual schematic so here you can see you
have two samples sample a
sample b um you're not no
unknown microbiota in each of these
samples um and for each one you have to
follow
this workflow you call your purification
in this case doing the rna purification
you know if you're looking for virus
bacterial fungi you know these could be
potentially be three separate workflows
you're looking at and then for each one
is it pcr is it immunology culture
so you can imagine for each sample it
can take a few hours there are very
quick tests to
a week or more especially if you have to
culture
and so for two samples not so bad um
but as you start to increase the number
of samples the
amount of testing increases
almost exponentially and so um it
becomes
kind of a burden as far as time
and effort and so one of the
large benefits of molecular workflow is
it takes this
um you know what can become a very
complicated
system and simplifies it and so you
end up with a very simple and
comprehensive workflow for pathogen
detection
it also allows a very targeted analysis
of pathogens and so you're able to
look at you have a list of organisms of
interest
and you're able to look at those very
specifically so if you look see again
you have your sample type a your sample
type b
but both of them go through the same
workflow they go through the dna rna
purification or total nucleic acid
purification
followed by quantitative pcr and so
you're able to start from your sample
get to your results in a very manageable
amount of time and again
so you have the same workflow and so you
add
increased number of samples however your
workflow doesn't change
you're still able to have your very
simple and comprehensive
protocol or workflow even though you've
increased your
your samples in this case going from two
to eight
and so not only can you look at specific
samples but
it allows for kind of more of a
screening monitoring
of a larger number of samples as well as
a larger number of microbes
and pathogens
and so that's kind of the basis big
introduction to the molecular workflow
but then a little bit more details about
the workflow um
and so when i say workflow this is
essentially what i'm describing
um it's it looks you know and
laid out like this it is relatively
simple until you start getting into the
details it gets more complicated
but the first thing as with most you
start off with sample collection
and storage we won't really delve deep
into this today we just don't have the
time
but this can be very critical to good
results downstream
so once you have your sample collected
and then
stored or shipped to you then it goes
through the sample lysis
really what i'll be focusing on in this
part of the webinar
is the enzymatic or chemical lysis i
think madu did a really good job
describing the mechanical
b-beading lysis used for the microbiome
kit
and then once you've lysed your sample
you go into
actually extracting nucleic acids and
then taking that nucleic acid
downstream into real-time pcr
and so these two areas your sample lysis
nucleic acid extraction and downstream
pcr you have quite a number of options
as far as methods in order to do this
um all the way from low throughputs
to high throughput or more automated
workflows and so
if you look at them separately for
sample purification
you can think of it as having three
flavors you have your spin columns your
organic extraction
um and then your more high throughput or
automated system
and so spin columns and organic
extraction they're going to be
more of your traditional methods um
organic extraction trisol or similar
spin columns such as a pure link column
these are the gold standards and work
very well however they tend to be more
labor intensive
require more hazardous chemicals and
often can require centrifugation so
for a smaller number of samples they
work fine but if you're starting to get
in the tens the hundreds
even the thousands it becomes very
untenable to use these two methods and
so that's when you would switch to your
automated system um which can vary in
types um for us we use
a magnetic b based system which can be
performed manually
or um as we like to do it with automate
with um
instrumentation um to relieve the burden
of hands-on time um and though they work
very well
very useful for high throughput um they
are not without their limits
um you know everything really is a
trade-off you get your higher throughput
but
you are you know the protocols are more
fixed
um your application areas are more fixed
um so
but it does offer a good option
uh for pathogen detection
in addition you do also have throughput
options related to your real-time pcr
um all the way from your single tube
assays
which are your most low throughput
ideal for a fewer number of samples and
does i guess you could say offer the
most
flexible option as far as number
of assays to be run and then you have
your
array these either come in a plate or
card format
um you know the the plates allow for a
large number of samples for
fewer number of assays whereas the
arrays a fewer number of samples a
larger number of assays
these would fall more into your low to
medium throughput
options um also they come
as fixed but they also do come
customizable
and then you have your final offering
the most high throughput
option and these are your open array
plates
like the arrays they are pre-spotted
either with the standard
offering or a fixed offering or
customizable
and allows you to process up to 48
samples
and then even up to
a larger number of assays and so you can
imagine
for one run you're able to generate a
very large amount
of information these opinionary plates
are probably most useful for screening
or profiling type of
experiments
and so um i've kind of spoken briefly
about the high throughput
options for the workflow and now i kind
of want to go
a little deeper and kind of what we
offer and the benefits
so really the benefits there are
multiple benefits i will say probably
the two
biggest ones we talk about are going to
be user time
and then consistency and so
user time or hands-on time is another
way to think of it is
a huge time suck uh for a lab if you
have to have a tech
performing the extraction and it takes a
full hour of hands-on time
you know that that's a lot of time and
then you add number of samples and that
can increase exponentially
and so by using a high throughput or
even an automated workflow you're able
to the same amount of time
the attraction may take the same amount
of time but the actual hands-on time is
5 or 10 minutes
leaving you know if you have an hour
protocol 50 minutes that the tech is
able to do
other um tasks and so
your user time becomes more productive
and less um you know focused on the task
you can do more multitasking
the other is inconsistent results you
know anytime you have a step which
requires human hands the potential for
variability is much higher as opposed to
using
a instrument or automated system
having a robot do it you'll get much
higher reproducibility versus
or much less variability versus human
hands and so those are the two
biggest areas that high throughput where
high-throughput
methods or protocols in the context of
molecular pathogen detection
workflows that they can benefit
um kind of three other ways the
potential for increased sensitivity
again you know you're using a system
that has more automation or more um
you know instrumentation which allows
increased consistency which can help
with sensitivity
kind of already mentioned the the
reduction in user
hands-on time um but again significant
time savings
as because from one sample say up to 96
samples it's the same amount of time and
so
kind of look at that as more bang for
your buck for the same amount of time
and then of course the increased
productivity you know if you don't have
a tax sitting
performing extraction for an hour if
they're only hands-on for five minutes
then you know that's more they can get
done in a day
and also potentially more samples that
can get run in the day
so um you know high throughput
especially high throughput combined with
automation
we can provide a very useful and
productive workflow
and so for us i mentioned that for our
automation our high throughput we use a
magnetic bead-based extraction system
we also combine that with
instrumentation
specifically our kingfisher instruments
and these
run the gamut from automation light
using our duo prime
system which has benefits
of a instrument to perform most of the
extraction tasks but it's a low
essentially a low throughput you can
only run six to twelve samples
um but you know to trade off a small
footprint smaller number of samples
but you get the benefit of the
consistency
and if you're only running say 20
samples 24 samples a day
that system works great uh the next on
the list is kind of our semi-automation
offering so this is going to be our
kingfisher flex system
the nice thing about this system is you
can run
up to 96 samples or 24 if you're using
the
deep well plate but it provides a medium
to high throughput
method where you get the benefit of
automation an automated system for
consistency
but you do still have some up front
steps as far as
liquid handling or filling
and then finally we have the full
automation option
which is our kingfisher presto which
really to get the full benefit of this
system you have to combine it with the
robotic liquid handler something like a
t-can
or a hamilton and this provides you your
walk-away
option as well as an ultra-high
throughput option
again similar to the flex 96 to 24
samples per run
but um
still you're able to walk away which
reduces the hands-on time even further
and so with these instrument systems
we've also developed chemistries
to go along with them to provide users
with
the easiest and most comprehensive
options and so i'll focus on
really two of our pathogen detection
kits
so the first is our magmax spiral
pathogen tonal clay gas kit
which should be very familiar to most
people by now
especially if you're working with sars
kogi-2
but this kit covers kind of um
several slides ago i mentioned the two
kind of areas we focus on for
microbial and pathogen detection so this
is going to cover the viral
detection as well as some gram-negative
easy-to-lice bacteria
detection what's nice about it is it's
pretty flexible it's compatible with a
large number of samples
large number of viruses
flexible volume input range but the
extraction time is relatively short
that's 25 minutes and that is 25 minutes
on the kingfischer flex instrument for
example
now you can see data we've shown for
multiple sample types but
vtm is just viral transport media urine
for multiple different viruses as well
as gram-negative bacteria
indicating you know the ability of the
system
to work across multiple organisms sample
types
and provide a very flexible option
really our second offering this covers
the all pathogen
focus area this is magmax viral pathogen
ultra kit
and so it also covers the virus and
gram-negative bacteria but it does
include the harder to life
organisms such as gram-positive candida
these species as well as fungi like the
magmax pathogen it covers a wide range
of sample types as well as a wide range
of organisms
extraction time is longer in this case
but that is because it includes an
upfront enzymatic lysis really to ex
to be able to extract nucleic acid from
the gram positive
and the fungi or yeast species
and so these are used most often for
this data here especially is extracted
using a kingfisher flex
instrument however it is also compatible
using our presto
system combined with a liquid handler in
this case it was a
hamilton nimbus system and so here you
can see
um just comparing with you know the flex
to the nimbus
results are equivalent
for two different input types and for a
range
of targets and so again just showing
the flexibility and benefits of a high
throughput system
have our automated system however you
need to use it
so now i'll move on to the case studies
and all of these case studies use our
high throughput automated systems
both for the extraction as well as the
real-time pcr
so the first is looking at the magmax
viral pathogen ultra kit
here we had a respiratory tract
microbiota
open array plate
it targets 44 different pathogens and so
we wanted to be able to
detect see what we could detect from
extraction
from bronchoravial or lavage samples or
ball samples
and so using those samples
we used them straight or combined them
with
different spike in organisms extracted
with our magmax viral pathogen
ultra system um and kingfisher flex
and then performed the open array
protocol real-time pcr protocol which
includes a pre-amplification
step um the entire workflow we process
you can process up to 96 samples within
eight hours
and so a very relatively fast
system which gives you a very large
amount of
data to work with
and so um so here outlines so these are
all the different targets included
on the open array plate um and then from
our spikens these diamonds
indicate the expected
um positive samples for the um spike in
positives
um lava samples what's interesting
is looking at all of the samples
we knew what we should detect and then
so we were
able to detect all of those and then we
were able to confirm
samples that had previous test results
and then also able to detect a large
amount of samples that we didn't know
were in
large amount of organisms that we didn't
know were in those samples so
um you know a very useful
system and high sensitivity and so here
is just kind of outlining the green
indicates um what should have been
detected based on our spikens
so you can see the spike in samples
detected them whereas the no spike in
samples did not so that looks good
the purple indicates what we did detect
but we're not spiked in
so potentially present in
those different samples which is very
interesting and the blue
indicates results
matching results from previous detection
and so all that was detected
previously was redetected when we tested
these samples again
so um
able to generate a large amount of data
um
relatively short amount of time and a
you know
low amount of effort um the same is true
we
did also have an open array plate which
has a vaginal microbiota targets on it
and so using the same protocol we're
able to
kind of have the similar output just a
different
list of organisms
also with our magma spiral pathogen kit
just looking at virus and gram negative
we have done comparisons against kits
out in the field just to confirm that we
were performing
as expected or as customers would expect
so here we're looking at
um negative single-stranded rna virus
and then positive single-strand rna
virus and then
double-stranded dna virus so compared to
the competitors
equivalents are actually improved
performance and then we also we were
interested to see how low could we go
as far as viral copies into extraction
and so
we were able to find for human blood and
human plasma detect
as low as 50 copies spiked into a 400
microliter extraction for cmd
and ebv
um kind of more relevant to what's going
on in the world today
um the magmax viral pathogen kit as well
as its
um later version the magnetic sparrow
pathogen 2 kit
have been used to extract a star's cov2
virus and then detect using tacman
assays and so you can see
we were able to correctly detect three
of the gene targets for stars cov2 as
well as a
extraction control for two different
volumes at different concentrations
and so um actually a very pretty
sensitive system that works really well
and then finally our most recent
extraction
protocol the interest in saliva or the
ability to
use saliva as a sample type for viral
nucleic acid detection
has skyrocketed especially over the last
couple of months
and so we wanted to make sure that we
had a protocol
that would match or be able to be used
with saliva
due to the nature of saliva it does
require its own protocol
it cannot use the same protocol as for
example vial transport
media and so we developed a protocol for
the mvp and mdp2
kit for raw or stabilized saliva
and so here you can see um
um reacts one of our tests is we took
saliva either
raw and diluted in pbs or from
stabilized and stabilizing gene fix
reagent
spiked in some
inactivated respiratory pathogens
and then extracted them using the mvp1
and mvp2
and then detection from real-time pcr
so here you can see uh we use the five
viral targets are from the spike ends
and then 16s
is an endogenous um control and so what
you can see
for over 48 saliva samples
between the raw and the stabilized you
see equivalent
uh results for the five spiked in virus
as you would expect
and then um 16s was detected in all
samples but at different levels again
as you would expect and so um
you know using a high throughput
automated method um provides you for
both extraction and for pcr
provides a very comprehensive workflow
flexible workflow um to reduce hands-on
time and get results
quicker and so that was
all i had thank you all very much for
your time
and i'll pass it back to the moderator
for questions
thank you sasha madhu and emily for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
goes to emily
if we want to extract nucleic acid from
gram-positive bacteria
and fungi and saliva which kit would you
recommend
for this i would recommend the in the
the magmaxro pathogen ultra kit
it has the upfront um enzymatic
treatment which will
up which will maximize recovery of
nucleic acids from
the gram-positive bacteria and fungi
okay thank you emily my next question
here is for madu
most of the microbiome studies are
focusing on human or mouth stool samples
what was the most exotic sample type you
tested
i have tested like wide range of sample
types as my presentation
also shows uh several vertebrates and uh
words also tested here and
the crazy samples that i tested is from
the grocery store
yeast samples and also like
the dust collected from the vacuum
cleaner
so those were all um tested
and also the most important uh sample
type tested
is the parasite so the gut stool sample
has so many
parasites if they have ibs syndrome or
some c difficile infection so we were
able to detect the parasites we were
able to extract the parasites with high
efficiency
this kit thank you madhu
my next question is for emily
what are the differences between the
saliva protocol for the magmax viral
pathogen kit versus the original
protocol
for use with other sample types
so the two protocols are actually pretty
different they do follow the same
um basic outline of sample
pre-processing lysis extraction illusion
but one of the biggest differences was
the pre-processing
we actually in the protocol have very
specific instructions
on how to treat the saliva sample both
raw and stabilized
before going into the
actual extraction process mainly because
saliva samples are so variable
between collections and between um
different donors um the
pre-processing pre-processing steps we
developed help to kind of
normalize that so it increases your
chance of a good extraction
thank you emily my next question is for
madu
can we use kingfisher duo for automation
of magmax microbiome kit
what are the pros and cons versus
kingfisher flex
we can use the duo for the magmax
microbiome kit it was
already tested and it gives you
this as the flex
so the source is uh basically
um we can use less control
because if if the customer has few
samples to process
they can go with the duo if they have
more than
12 samples to process they can use the
flex instrument processor to
use the 96 deep well plate and
also like the eels are similar as i
already mentioned
um the only cons for the duo is we
cannot process more than 12 samples at a
time
okay thank you so much madhu my next
question is for emily
what is the average time to process 96
samples using the high throughput
extraction high throughput pcr
open array workflow
so average time it does depend kind of
on what open array
plate you're doing but i would say the
average
time is about eight hours
and that's from start to finish that's
from you have your sample in hand to
have your results off the instrument
okay thanks emily my next question is
for madu this is our last question
for sars wastewater surveillance you
showed concentration of the water
samples using filters
what other concentration options do you
recommend
um there are like wide variety of
options and
included in the publications like
worldwide like some people do peg
precipitation
and some people do ultra centrifugation
but we didn't test all these
options with our magmax microbiome kit
but when time permits we wanted to test
the peg precipitation
on these wastewater samples um it seems
like it's gonna concentrate the
wastewater samples pretty well
because we have tested with the cell
culture media and it works pretty good
so we need to test more options on this
thank you again sasha madhu and emily
for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labruz and our
sponsors thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
the next installment of the prep for
success webinar series takes place
february 11th and focuses on vaccine
development
so please join us for that until next
time
goodbye